Would it be okay for me with the Rebuilder?
So again the Rebuilder is a tool that is
FDA approved for
Peripheral Neuropathy, so that's this question is about would it be okay for me with the Rebuilder to put the self-adhered
Electroves on part of
The part of my knees that I have numbness. How do I do that both electrodes on the same D or one electrode on one?
D and one on the other D
so if you do the
Self-adhered electrodes, you could do that on your knees one on one D one on the other. There's no there's no negative about it
But I would do opposite sides of the body
So you would do one on one D one on the other
however, so
You're always best in treating neuropathy
Treating the most distal point
So let's say let's say you didn't have any neuropathy in your feet, but you had neuropathy in your knees. No
Nobody would ever have that. Well, let's pretend that I had that. I mean, I guess somebody may have that, but almost always you're going to get
neuropathy in the most distal part of your body because
neuropathy is either
Diabetes-induced neuropathy and it's because of the excess glucose that it's damaging the nerves. It's always going to be in the most distal part
Or if you have chemotherapy induced neuropathy, it's always going to be in the most distal part because you have the least amount of circulation circulating
The toxins back out of your body and detoxing that part of your body. So that's what where the peripheral nerves are most damaged
You're always from a treatment perspective. You're always best off treating most distally
Reading furthest away from your body. So you're treating your feet is always still the best option
Um, so well I am my feet are much better, but it's really in my knees now. Still you're still better off treating the feet because you're going to fire that holder pathway. So it's firing. They
The eferited a ferret pathway. You're just better off going the more distal possible. So leading farthest away from the heart as possible.
So
That's that's how I would do it. I would you could do it with the pads and put it on each knee. I just wouldn't do that.
I purchased the socks that go with the rebuilder. Do you think they would be more effective than putting my feet in water? Try to decide to keep them or return them. I'd return them.
I don't like the socks. It's just you're going to be better off putting your feet in the water and doing it. You then it's going to go through the water and it's going to treat every part of the foot that's in the water.
Um, with the socks, you have to wet the socks, put the socks on. I just the reason why they came up with the socks was because some people just did not like putting their feet in water or some reason.
So people that had an a version of putting their feet in water would use the socks. I've never advocated to use the socks. I think it's much better just to put your feet in water. You're going to have a much more effective treatment.